brand new revelations surrounding DOJ
Inspector General Michael Horowitz today
Horowitz in fact appeared on Capitol
Hill and where he faced questions from
Republican lawmakers about the unethical
conduct of mr. super Patriot himself Jim
Comey now this was the I geez first
public testimony since he issued that
unprecedented rebuke of the fired FBI
director and a report solely focused on
one small issue come--the illicit
leaking and in that report Horowitz
noted that the fired FBI director set a
dangerous example for everyone in the
FBI and today Horowitz doubled down on
this damning accusation explained that
the office of the Inspector General was
concerned that commis actions will set a
troubling precedent and as I have said
before this just the beginning for Jim
Comey super Patriot this is the tip of
the iceberg this is the low-hanging
fruit call me as escaped charges so far
but Horowitz he's just getting started
let's see what happens now keep in mind
the most damning evidence of commis
rampant abuse of power stems from two
issues that Horowitz was unable to
discuss today that includes the horowitz
investigation into the FISA abuse and
then later the Durham bar investigation
into the origins of the Russia
witch-hunt and to top it all off just
today Horowitz indicated that he would
also look into irregularities
surrounding Comey sworn testimony on
Capitol Hill members showed lack of
candor let's see where this goes and
Horowitz also seemingly agreed that
Comey tried to deceive president-elect
Trump during the now-infamous meeting at
Trump Tower in early 2017 by probing
Trump for information and reaction to
the dirty dossier that he said was
salacious and unverified what he didn't
tell the president is that just a couple
of months earlier a couple of months
hang on a couple of months earlier yeah
he was signing a FISA warrant based on
Hillary Clinton's dirty Russian dossier
yeah the one that he didn't verify the
one that he was warned wasn't true on
multiple occasions we know of three
there may be as many as five or more
occasions Comey and others were warned
don't trust Christopher Steele and the
fact that the president-elect remember
he told him in that Trump Tower meaning
he was not the subject and of
Investigation
that was also a huge lie and it was one
of the many traps that Comey said in
what was Operation crossfire hurricane
and a brand-new book from commis former
assistant says tonight
his one-time boss recklessly bucked
protocol in order to set up Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn as we've been
telling you saying quote we just decided
you know screw it well remember call me
bragging about taking advantage of
general Flynn he sent it as
investigators to the White House to
question him during the first few
chaotic days of the incoming
administration day four to be specific
it was from the beginning a perjury trap
plain and simple is like a tag team
Andrew McCabe says oh you don't need a
lawyer and Comey says he did something
he'd never do under the bush or Obama
administrations and then sadly and
perhaps more importantly a 33 year
veteran of this country was told he
didn't need a lawyer when he absolutely
needed a lawyer is that how we now treat
our veterans that's how call me mr.
super Patriot he's treating an American
war hero served this country 33 years
two foreign wars with the boomerang of
Justice as we've been telling you is now
in full effect now in the coming days
weeks pay very close attention because
the next shooter drop will be the AG's
findings on FISA abuse he signed three
of the four warrants that means Comey
the Inspector General's completed report
is now in the hands of the Attorney
General bar who along with the FBI
director Ray is reviewing this material
for possible reductions now director Ray
seems to be hesitant he really does in
wanting to fix what is the greatest the
premiere law enforcement agency in the
entire world
I hope director ray changes course and
commits himself to implementing the
changes so the 99.9% of law-abiding FBI
agents that keep us safe every day that
we can have confidence in all of them
this is about 1/10 of 1%
now the changes here he needs to look at
our so we prevent the massive abuse of
power so it'll never happen again